So, first thing is, like, I want to do that too, but let me get through it. The cults tend to operate by having, sometimes through a charismatic leader, sometimes through a teaching or some sort of ritual process of trusting the process. What they do is they take you and they say, here are all of these things that you need. And then that diagnosis is usually right. If you look at somebody like a Keith Raniere, if you look at somebody like Keith Raniere's of the NXIVM cult, which the documentary The Vow and what's the other one, Seduced? There may be a third one now i don't know uh what they're doing is they're going up and they're making a diagnosis so he goes up to sarah edmondson and he says you're coughing but you're not sick and you're doing that because you think that you have to be sick to get attention who are you without that and it changes
首先，我想说我也想做这件事，但让我先把它讲完。邪教通常通过魅力型领袖、某种教义或某种信任过程的仪式来运作。他们所做的是把你拉进去，然后告诉你，这些就是你所需要的一切。这种诊断通常是正确的。如果你看看像基思·拉尼尔（Keith Raniere）这样的人，看看NXIVM邪教的基思·拉尼尔，纪录片《誓言》（The Vow）和另一部叫什么来着，《诱惑》（Seduced）？现在可能还有第三部，我不知道。他们所做的是进行诊断，他走到莎拉·埃德蒙森（Sarah Edmondson）面前说，你在咳嗽，但你并没有生病，你这样做是因为你认为必须生病才能得到关注，没有了这些你又是谁？这改变了
her life because she's like i've done this my whole life my dad gave me attention when i was sick or whatever she says i don't remember her psychoanalysis of herself, but she says basically that woke her up. So then she's kind of in a vulnerable state where she feels like she doesn't know who she is, but she's ready for growth. She sees this thing that's been holding her back. And then Keith Raniere says, okay, you got to do this process. And you understand how, and I'm not going to go through the whole NXIVM indoctrination,
她的人生，因为她觉得我这辈子一直都是这样，我爸爸在我生病时会给我关注，或者诸如此类。我不记得她对自己的心理分析了，但她基本上说那让她觉醒了。所以她处于一种脆弱的状态，觉得不知道自己是谁，但她准备好成长了。她看到了阻碍自己的东西。然后基思·拉尼尔说，好吧，你必须完成这个过程。你明白，我不会详细讲述整个NXIVM的洗脑过程，
but the diagnosis is right. You know, charismatic leaders, cults, if it's like a text or something that people can kind of project on or sort of vague or has a process, it's going to leave room for people to do this diagnostic part in a way that is unique to them because not everyone's running from a different thing. We all have a different shadow. And so what Keith Raniere did and what most cult leaders are able to do is come up and say, oh, my gosh, you have a father wound. You have a father shaped hole.
但诊断是正确的。你知道，魅力型领袖、邪教，如果它像是一本人们可以投射情感的文本，或者某种模糊的东西，或者有一套流程，它就会给人们留下空间，以一种对他们独特的方式进行这种诊断，因为并不是每个人都在逃避同样的事情。我们每个人都有不同的阴影。所以基思·拉尼尔所做的，以及大多数邪教领袖能够做到的，就是走过来对你说，天哪，你有父亲创伤。你心里有一个父亲形状的空洞。
And you've been trying to stuff that with drugs your whole life. And you've been trying to stuff that with music and this other identity and sex or whatever. And now you're trying to make me be your father and project that energy on me. But I'm not going to accept it. You need to become your own father. And the person's like, oh, wow, you know, that diagnosis is real, right? That somebody can diagnose what you're running from and you're suffering and they can still have a prescription that is complete bullshit. And sort of that is what advertising is, right? Like, and, you know, and advertising isn't necessarily a cult, but they are operating
你这辈子一直试图用毒品来填补它。你一直试图用音乐、其他身份、性或者其他什么东西来填补它。现在你试图让我成为你的父亲，并把那种能量投射到我身上。但我不会接受。你需要成为你自己的父亲。那个人会觉得，哦，哇，你知道，那个诊断是真的，对吧？有人能诊断出你在逃避什么，你在受什么苦，而且他们还能给出一个完全是胡扯的处方。某种程度上，这就是广告，对吧？而且，你知道，广告不一定是邪教，但它们运作的
on that same mechanism where Starbucks is saying in the nineties, hey, you think a coffee shop is like a cat and some books or whatever. That isn't. It's a new way of life, okay? If you're younger, you have no idea what I'm talking about, okay? Because you don't remember what a world was before Starbucks. But Apple Computer, if you're, you know, some of you may be too young to remember this, but it was like they came on the scene and they said, this computer is not like, and I'm specifically talking about their advertising, you know, don't send me an email and say, well, computers used to not be intuitive. And Steve Jobs wanted to say, well, the, this is a bicycle for your brain. This is supposed to work. Okay. I'm not talking about the actual
机制是一样的。就像星巴克在九十年代说，嘿，你以为咖啡店就是一只猫和几本书之类的东西吗？不是的。这是一种新的生活方式，好吗？如果你比较年轻，你根本不知道我在说什么，好吗？因为你不记得星巴克出现之前的世界是什么样了。但苹果电脑，如果你们，你知道，有些人可能太年轻不记得了，但当时他们出现时说，这台电脑不像，我特别指的是他们的广告，你知道，别给我发邮件说，嗯，电脑以前并不直观。史蒂夫·乔布斯想说，嗯，这是为你大脑准备的自行车。这应该是有效的。好吧，我不是在谈论实际的
product. I'm talking about the way it was marketed. Okay. So like Apple computers said, here's an artist blowing dust off a thing they built in their studio. And they have this Apple computer and they have this thing. And here's this guy going on this long journey and the iPad's in the leather case. And he's a bespoke gentleman checking his thing. And they were trying to say these people live intentionally. They live artistically. They have a very small quantity of very nice things because those nice things cost a lot of money. Um, you
产品。我是在谈论它的营销方式。好吧。所以苹果电脑说，看，这是一个艺术家在工作室里吹掉他们建造的东西上的灰尘。他们有这台苹果电脑，他们有这个东西。这里有个人正在进行一段漫长的旅程，iPad放在皮套里。他是一位定制绅士在检查他的东西。他们试图说这些人是有意地生活。他们艺术地生活。他们拥有极少量非常好的东西，因为那些好东西很贵。嗯，你
know, the computer is next to the heirloom watch or knife because it's going to be the same thing. It's going to last forever. It's not computers don't last forever. Um, but you're supposed to feel that and intuit that. Okay. And that diagnosis of like, you want to be an artist doesn't mean that you need an apple, that diagnosis of like, I want to go on this thing to have this part of my life. I want to have a new way of life. That doesn't mean that you need an apple. That diagnosis of like, I want to go on this thing to have this part of my life. I want to have a new way of life. That doesn't mean that you need a cup of Starbucks coffee. The diagnosis in a cult and a conspiracy theory in predatory therapy, in predatory religion, like you'll see the same thing in religion. They'll get that. I mean, a ton of religions, they lead with this, these basically like self-help techniques from the
知道，电脑放在传家宝手表或刀具旁边，因为它们是一样的。它们会永远持续下去。不是说电脑会永远持续下去。嗯，但你应该感觉到并直觉到这一点。好吧。那种“你想成为艺术家”的诊断并不意味着你需要一台苹果电脑，那种“我想通过这个东西来拥有我生活的一部分，我想拥有新的生活方式”的诊断，并不意味着你需要一台苹果电脑。那种“我想通过这个东西来拥有我生活的一部分，我想拥有新的生活方式”的诊断，并不意味着你需要一杯星巴克咖啡。邪教、阴谋论、掠夺性疗法、掠夺性宗教中的诊断，就像你在宗教中也会看到同样的事情。他们会引导这一点。我的意思是，大量的宗教，他们带头使用这些基本上来自七十年代的自助技巧。
seventies. Now, like I've had people tell me, well, yeah, you're just running from stuff. You know, you don't know that you have a black hole in your heart that you're trying to stop with all this other stuff. They don't even know where that line came from. You know, their pastor or something said it to them. Um, but you know, like that came from human potential type cults in the seventies and, um, synonym and things like that. So like a lot of these things make a diagnosis and then they tell you that you have to do something to feel better or you have to do something to be whole. Okay. So that's what makes it a cult is that in that spot, that person is taking away, they're, they're clocking you, making you feel like you're moving towards authenticity.
现在，就像有人告诉我，嗯，是的，你只是在逃避事情。你知道，你不知道你的心里有一个黑洞，你正试图用所有其他东西来填补它。他们甚至不知道那句话是从哪里来的。你知道，他们的牧师或什么人对他们说了这句话。嗯，但你知道，那来自七十年代的人类潜能型邪教，以及辛农（Synanon）之类的东西。所以很多这些东西做出诊断，然后告诉你必须做点什么才能感觉更好，或者你必须做点什么才能变得完整。好吧。所以这就是它成为邪教的原因，在那一点上，那个人正在带走，他们正在锁定你，让你觉得你正在走向真实。
Then they're taking away your authenticity and they're replacing it with something else. And that something else is this thing that usually leads to exploitation of your time, exploitation of your sexuality, exploitation of your. Sometimes it's just your attention that these some people will settle just for being an egomania. You know, a lot of these kind of cults of personality are just that. But it replaces it with something that is self-serving to a small group of people or a person or a group. And then it's going to put you in a position where you are supposed to go out and do the same thing on a smaller scale. Now, you're not going to get as much of the reward as the founder. Usually your reward is going to be ego. But you're doing the abuse and you're a
然后他们带走了你的真实，并用其他东西取代了它。而那个其他东西通常会导致对你时间的剥削、对你性的剥削、对你的剥削。有时只是你的注意力，有些人甚至满足于成为自大狂。你知道，很多这种个人崇拜只是那样。但它用一些对一小群人、一个人或一个团体有利的东西取代了它。然后它会把你放在一个位置，让你去以更小的规模做同样的事情。现在，你不会像创始人那样获得那么多的回报。通常你的回报是自我满足。但你正在实施虐待，而你是一个
good person and you think you feel well. So what you're doing is an abuse. So that means you're not being abused. You get it? And that's why so many people who come out of these things, they have such problems because not only, if I admit that that guy damaged me enough to start the healing and change process, I have to sit with the shame and guilt that I hurt all these other people. And so vulnerability is always going to be switched and replaced in a cult. Okay. That's a cult. The difference in a cult and a conspiracy theory, or I think conspiracy movement might be a better term because there's conspiracy theories that are right, right? And I know the thing happened. I just don't agree with the thing that people are doing with it. And then there's also conspiracy theories that are wildly insane and are just not real, but the movement around them is like pretty mainstreamed so i don't know that the theory itself is the problem i'm going to say conspiracy movement right so the conspiracy conspiracy theory how that difference differs from a cult right is that
好人，你认为你感觉很好。所以你所做的是一种虐待。这意味着你没有被虐待。你明白吗？这就是为什么这么多从这些东西中走出来的人有这么多问题，因为不仅如此，如果我承认那个人伤害我到足以开始治愈和改变的过程，我必须面对我伤害了所有其他人的羞耻和内疚。所以脆弱性在邪教中总是会被转换和取代。好吧。这就是邪教。邪教和阴谋论的区别，或者我认为阴谋运动可能是一个更好的术语，因为有正确的阴谋论，对吧？我知道事情发生了。我只是不同意人们用它做的事情。然后还有疯狂的、根本不真实的阴谋论，但围绕它们的运动相当主流，所以我不知道理论本身是不是问题，我要说阴谋运动。所以阴谋论，它与邪教的区别，对吧，在于
with a conspiracy theory you are feeling um a group of people is deciding that there is a course of action because that's one of the reasons I don't like theory, is people sitting around and diagnosing this thing and talking about it and writing books about it or believing it or going to church to talk about it or going to academia to talk about it or school to talk about it and just talking about it anywhere. That isn't a conspiracy theory, right? Because conspiracy theory involves action. Now, the action might be talking, right? The difference is that the conspiracy theory, you've made the leap that what you are doing is messianic, is important, is fighting back,
对于阴谋论，你感觉嗯，一群人正在决定有一个行动方针，因为这就是我不喜欢“理论”这个词的原因之一，人们坐在一起诊断这件事，谈论它，写书，或者相信它，或者去教堂谈论它，或者去学术界谈论它，或者去学校谈论它，在任何地方谈论它。那不是阴谋论，对吧？因为阴谋论涉及行动。现在，行动可能是谈话，对吧？区别在于阴谋论，你已经跨越了那一步，认为你正在做的事情是救世主的，是重要的，是在反击，
is empowering you against the forces of darkness in a way. Now, a cult can't really empower you the same way a conspiracy theory can, right? Because Keith Raniere, he needs you working all of the time. He needs your finances and your sexuality and your whatever. Like, you've got to be tired. You've got to be exhausted. Matthew Rimsky was talking about one of the high control groups he was in, and he was saying that the only time where he had time to realize that he was in a cult was when he was in the kitchen, because he just got to feel a little moment of joy while he made something. I mean, he was making it a slave
在某种程度上是在增强你的力量。现在，邪教不能像阴谋论那样真正增强你的力量，对吧？因为基思·拉尼尔，他需要你一直工作。他需要你的财务、你的性生活和你的任何东西。就像，你必须很累。你必须精疲力竭。马修·里姆斯基（Matthew Remsky）在谈论他所在的其中一个高控制团体时说，他唯一能意识到自己身处邪教的时间是在厨房里，因为他在做东西时能感受到一点点快乐。我的意思是，他是在为这个组织做奴隶
labor for this organization. But it was like one of the only places where he could feel himself because he was so tired of going in the process, it wears you down. You can't clock out of NXIVM and then go do QAnon and storm the Capitol. Like, there's not, you don't have time to do that. The conspiracy movement is taking something and saying, this action is actually empowering. It is good. It is going to get you to fight back, and you're making a difference. So a cult is giving you a false sense of authenticity, right? An authentic self. A conspiracy movement, and i know there's some overlap but but its main mission is is it's giving you a false sense of agency you know they're making the frogs gay they're making the kids gay the disney movies are contaminated you know no one knows that jesus
劳动。但这几乎是他唯一能感受到自己的地方，因为他太累了，无法参与这个过程，它会磨损你。你不能在NXIVM下班，然后去搞匿名者Q（QAnon）并冲击国会大厦。就像，没有，你没有时间做那个。阴谋运动是拿走某样东西并说，这个行动实际上是增强力量的。它是好的。它会让你反击，你正在做出改变。所以邪教给你一种虚假的真实感，对吧？一个真实的自我。阴谋运动，我知道有一些重叠，但它的主要使命是它给你一种虚假的代理感，你知道，他们让青蛙变弯，他们让孩子变弯，迪士尼电影被污染了，你知道，没人知道耶稣
is coming back whatever the cult is doing it's saying all this stuff and then it's telling you that if you get on Facebook and you post, you're fighting back, you're in this, you may just be talking about it, like I said, but the talk becomes the action and that we have this little bubble of people and we're spreading the word and it's growing and it's on 4chan and you've got to go out and find younger kids and then co-opt their style and their culture and bring them into this thing. And people are waking up and people in other countries are even supporting us that feels like i'm doing something that is empowering to me that's less about my authentic self being replaced by a leader or group or a high control system and it more is
要回来了，无论邪教在做什么，它都在说所有这些东西，然后它告诉你，如果你上Facebook并发布帖子，你就是在反击，你参与其中，你可能只是在谈论它，就像我说的，但谈话变成了行动，我们有这个小群体，我们正在传播这个词，它正在增长，它在4chan上，你必须出去寻找更年轻的孩子，然后借用他们的风格和文化，把他们带进这个东西里。人们正在觉醒，其他国家的人甚至在支持我们，这感觉就像我正在做一些增强我力量的事情，这与其说是我的真实自我被领袖、团体或高控制系统取代，不如说是
telling me something that's either negligibly effective or actually harmful to the world and myself is great you know that there's a secret conspiracy that on this pizza restaurant in DC that doesn't have a basement, um, there's actually a secret dungeon of kids. And I'm going to go shoot that up because Alex Jones told me to, um, that's a me feeling empowered to go act on behalf of as a conspiracy theory. So there's overlap between these things. They are technically different things. So where are they similar causationally i i think that they are very similar Thanks for watching! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
告诉我一些对世界和我自己要么效果微乎其微，要么实际上有害的事情，这很棒，你知道，有一个秘密阴谋，在华盛顿特区那家没有地下室的披萨店里，实际上有一个秘密的孩子地牢。我要去把它扫射了，因为亚历克斯·琼斯（Alex Jones）告诉我要这样做，那是我感到有权去代表阴谋论采取行动。所以这些事情之间有重叠。它们在技术上是不同的东西。那么它们在因果关系上有什么相似之处呢？我认为它们非常相似。感谢观看！本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。